fast 12.000 soldaten raus aus
deutschland die usa nennen details ihrer
truppen abzugspläne viele fragen an den
finanzminister die opposition will im
wirecard skandal antworten von der
bundesregierung und zocken bis zur sucht
kinder und jugendliche verbringen durch
corona deutlich mehr zeit mit
computerspielen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport ein sogenannter von mir
großer frust an den deutschen truppen
standorten der us-armee präsident macht
offenbar ernst weil deutschland aus
seiner sicht zu wenig für verteidigung
ausgibt will er knapp 12.000 seiner
35.000 soldaten kunden abziehen also
noch mehr als bislang geplant
folgende standorte sind betroffene
vilseck grafenwöhr und wildflecken in
bayern sowie spangdahlem in rheinland
pfalz die europa kommandozentrale in
stuttgart wird nach belgien verlegt 6400
soldaten kehren in die usa zurück 5600
sollen auf andere nato länder europas
verteilt werden
ein überblick von venedig die
ankündigung übertrifft alle deutschen
befürchtungen und der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister gibt hohe
strategische überlegungen vor wie ist es
mit diesem schritt stärken wir die
abschreckung russland und stärken die
nato außerdem werden die us-streitkräfte
flexibler 6400 soldaten sollen in die
usa zurückkehren mehr als 5400 innerhalb
europas verlegt werden
betroffen sind drei bundesländer auch
die stadt stuttgart bislang sitzt des
europa hauptquartiers der us
streitkräfte
so kann man nicht umgehen das ist sie
nur das modell des streifens und
bestrafen und will noch mal sagen unter
freunden ist sowas eigentlich nicht
üblich
bis heute ist nicht erklärbar und
begründbar warum die usa diese
entscheidung treffen natürlich treffen
sich souverän und selbstbewusst aber
dass das gut ist und dass das auch die
nato stärkt und das verhältnis
verbessert das kann ich mich verstellen
strafe statt freundschaft sprich das
offen aus
wir reduzieren jetzt aber wenn die
deutschen ihre rechnungen bezahlen denke
ich noch mal darüber nach die rechnungen
gemeint und deutschlands
verteidigungsausgaben für die nato
die findet tram zu gering und will nun
gleichzeitig soldaten in länder in
europa verlegen die prozentual weniger
in die nato kasse zahlen
das jump gegenwind vom kongress bekommt
hofft man nun in deutschland in der
kongress war bisher skeptisch in den
dingen die angekündigt worden ob man so
viel geld wo man eine vollkommen in
ordnung und technisch hochstehende
infrastruktur in deutschland hat obmann
us steuergeld in dieser höhe in die hand
nehmen muss um das an anderer stelle so
seien neu aufzubauen und hier ist das
geld
ein stück weit in den sand gesetzt wann
der abzug passieren soll ist der
amerikanische verteidigungsminister
offen er wird wissen warum fragen wir
nach bei ines trams in washington wird
es tatsächlich zu diesem truppenabzug
kommen verteidigungsminister sv hat
heute angedeutet dass die
truppenverlegung bereits binnen wochen
losgehen könnte genauso richtig ist aber
auch dass die verlegung einiger
einheiten monate wenn nicht jahre in
anspruch nehmen könnte entsprechend
könnte einen eventuellen neuer präsident
diesen teil der verlegung dann ab herbst
dieses jahres auch stoppen und wieder
rückgängig machen insgesamt so ist unser
eindruck ist da eine große skepsis im
verteidigungsministerium gegenüber
trumps plänen und entsprechend ist im
pentagon vieles auch noch mit blick auf
den truppenabzug ungeklärt auch mit
blick auf den kongress große unklarheit
denn es gibt dort wie gehört widerstände
und zwar bei demokraten und
republikanern gleichermaßen insofern ist
völlig unklar ob der kongress die gelder
für die truppenverlegung bereitstellen
wird es ist die rede davon dass die
verlegung bis zur milliarden von dollar
kosten wird und dann ist er noch trump
der scheint nach wie vor den
truppenabzug aus deutschland nutzen zu
wollen
als hebel gegenüber deutschland und er
sagt er deutet an
ich könnte mir das auch alles noch mal
überlegen fazit also der truppenabzug
ist konkreter geworden heute aber in
ganz trockenen tüchern ist er nach wie
vor nicht die einschätzung unserer
korrespondentin aus washington vielen
dank eines traums
nach berlin eigentlich hat das parlament
sommerpause doch der fall wirecard es so
außergewöhnlich und brisant dass der
finanzausschuss des bundestags heute
trotzdem zur sondersitzung zusammen kam
um herauszufinden warum der
finanzdienstleister solange betrügen
konnte ohne dass regierung oder
finanzaufsicht eingegriffen haben dazu
gleich mehr
zunächst fasst thomas konsum auf und
abstieg von wirecard kurz zusammen
wirecard 1999 gegründet ein lange
blühendes unternehmen bald der
börsengang steil geht's aufwärts
wirecard liebling der anleger hoffnung
der deutschen wirtschaft ab 2015 erste
schatten erste berichte über betrug etwa
in asien geschäft 2009 10 stellt die
finanzaufsicht bafin anzeige nicht gegen
wirecard gegen medienhäuser die den
betrug öffentlich machen vorwurf
marktmanipulationen juni paukenschlag
milliarden euro sind luftbuchungen ex
chef brown wird festgenommen die aktie
im absturz das unternehmen pleite
der fall wirecard über jahre checkten
wirtschaftsprüfer bilanzen sie fanden
nichts dafür fand das unternehmen etwas
berater karl theodor zu guttenberg etwa
er fand kontakte zu politikern auch
direkt im kanzleramt
beim finanzausschuss heute steht vor
allem finanzminister scholz unter druck
der mögliche kanzlerkandidat der spd
er soll erklären warum sein ministerium
nicht früher reagiert aus berlin klaus
brodbeck was wusste der finanzminister
und wann und was hat olaf scholz
möglicherweise versäumt die
koalitionsvertreter in der sitzung heute
im verteidigungs- modus wir haben auch
den minister gesehen der da keiner frage
aus weicht er zu allem auskunft gibt
aber das hat sich in den letzten wochen
ja schon angedeutet es ist eine komplexe
materie mit vielen vielen institutionen
die beteiligt sind zeigen dass das was
ihr geld ist ist das aus geprüft wird
und das andere sind alles
finanzgesellschaften die nicht geprüft
worden warum aber traf sich der
staatssekretär im finanzministerium mit
dem mittlerweile inhaftierten wirecard
boss warum setzte sich gar das
kanzleramt für die firma ein
schon fordern linke und fdp einen
untersuchungsausschuss
ich stehe ganz klar dafür mit meiner
meinung dass wir das nur es ist der
grösste bilanz kann ein
untersuchungsausschuss klären können das
müssen wir den anlegern dem finanzplatz
deutschland aber auch der nachhaltigkeit
dass so etwas nicht mehr passiert dass
milliarden an werden zerstört werden
das sind wir den menschen schuldig und
deswegen geht so etwas nur ernsthaft in
einem untersuchungsausschuss ich halte
einen untersuchungsausschuss für
unvermeidlich und zwar nicht weil er mir
besonders viel spaß machen würde da
meine abende drin zu verbringen aber es
verdichtet sich mein eindruck dass wir
vollen akten zugang brauchen wir haben
zum beispiel auch heute noch nicht die
gelegenheit das bundeskanzleramt zu
befragen
zu seiner rolle in dem ringer card
skandal wir haben das ganze thema
geldwäsche überhaupt noch nicht
vernünftig aufgearbeitet drei stunden
schon und noch kein ende in sicht
prognose das ist nur der auftakt
eigentlich sollte längst schluss sein
mit der befragung des finanzministers
theo koll in berlin warum dauert es so
lange nun allein die grünen 89 fragen
eingereicht haben und die fdp ganze 22
seiten mit fragen also auch die nächste
sondersitzung ist hier schon garantiert
scholz versucht offensichtlich alles um
auch die abgeordneten zuzugehen
teilnehmer meinte eben der
finanzminister habe die beantwortung
aller restlichen fragen bis zum 10
august oder um den 10 august zugesagt
ziel muss es für scholz ja sein einen
untersuchungsausschuss zu vermeiden denn
der würde weit in den
bundestagswahlkampf fragen und wäre ein
klotz am bein eines möglichen
kanzlerkandidaten scholz für die
einsetzung eines solchen ausschusses ist
ein viertel der abgeordneten nötig das
heißt drei oppositionsparteien vertreter
der fdp und der linke sind dafür fdp und
grüne wollen ist von der heutigen
befragung abhängig machen in gewisser
weise hat also scholz ist auch heute
selbst in der hand dankeschön nach
berlin theo koll anderes großes thema
heute die arbeitsverhältnisse in der
fleischbranche wie beschämend die sind
hatten die korona massen infektionen in
verschiedenen schlachtbetrieben bewiesen
jetzt zieht das kabinett konsequenzen ab
kommendem jahr werden werksverträge und
leiharbeit im fleisch betrieben verboten
5 prozent der unternehmen sollen ab 2026
jährlich
trainiert werden und es gibt
mindeststandards für gemeinsame
unterkünfte dominik müller sl fasst
zusammen
genervt vom büro job dann hat nach
deutschland in einen schlachthof dort
lässt sich gutes geld verdienen
im rumänischen fernsehen preisen
subunternehmen mit solchen werbevideos
die arbeit in schlachtbetrieben bietern
äußern
doch dann in deutschland arbeiten im
akkord oftmals lohndumping und
wuchermieten für ein bett in einer
massen unterkunft der schlachtbetrieb
bislang fein raus die arbeiter sind ja
nicht bei ihm sondern bei einem
subunternehmen angestellt wir werden
dieser verschleierung und dieser
organisierten verantwortungslosigkeit
ein ende setzen und in der
fleischindustrie gründlich aufräumen es
geht um klare regeln
es geht um klare verantwortung und so
gehört sich das auch in einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft ab kommendem jahr sind
werkverträge und leiharbeit verboten
schlachthöfe müssen ihre arbeiter dann
selbst einstellen
das ist der richtige schritt in die
richtige richtung wir hören uns das
jetzt im detail angucken
das tun die unternehmen sicherlich auch
die werden auch lücken suchen
die wertungen gehen können aber wir
hoffen dass der gesetzgeber da
konsequent ist und das komplett
verbietet in kuba ist ein sub
unternehmer seine rumänischen arbeiter
schlachten und zerlegen in deutschen
schlachthöfen zu fairen bedingungen wie
er betont er ärgert sich dass nun wegen
einiger schwarzer schafe das ganze werk
vertrags system abgeschafft wird und
warnt vor konsequenzen nicht verboten
und dort können die schönen stunden aber
ein für 250 euro 15
und dann haben wir es gar nicht unter
kontrolle dann wird das fleisch was in
spanien produziert wird oder osteuropäer
produziert wird gilt hier eingeführt
von solchen szenarien will sich der
minister nicht beeindrucken lassen
angesichts der milliarden gewinne die
die branche verzeichnet es müsse
hierzulande fair zugehen
das kabinett hat auch
steuererleichterungen auf den weg
gebracht vor allem für familien ab
januar soll der kinderfreibetrag um mehr
als 500 euro erhöht werden
zudem steigt das kindergeld um 15 euro
monatlich auf 219 euro für die ersten
beiden kinder
auf 225 für das dritte und auf 250 ab
dem vierten und der grundfreibetrag wird
ebenfalls angehoben einkommen bis und
10.000 euro sind steuerfrei
stichwort corona da macht der kreis
dithmarschen in schleswig-holstein
sorgen dort ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen in den vergangenen tagen
stark gestiegen
es sind vor allem urlaubsrückkehrer vom
westbalkan und aus skandinavien
hannah hebestreit hat einzelheiten habe
in dithmarschen hat das zeug zu einem
neuen corona hotspot mehrere dutzend
heimkehrer aus dem urlaub haben das
virus mit nach hause gebracht und
offenbar angehörige angesteckt
die zahl der infizierten nähert sich der
grenze ab der einen landkreis als
risikogebiet gilt schon jetzt muss heute
gegen die verbreitung des virus in der
stadt vorgehen
wir werden sicherlich maßnahmen bekommen
die auch einschränkung bedeuten aber wie
sie es ganz konkret darstellt das werden
wir heute abend sehen aber wir werden
nicht den zustand des lockdown sie im
märz haben
gelingt es nicht die verbreitung des
virus zu stoppen droht auch urlaubern
die hier ihre ferien verbringen zu hause
ein test oder quarantäne
im lagezentrum des nachbarkreises
rendsburg eckernförde
beobachten sie ebenfalls dass die
meisten infektionen von reiserückkehrern
mitgebracht werden das gesundheitsamt
bietet seit heute tests an für alle die
aus risikogebieten kommen zum nulltarif
der volkswirtschaftliche schaden der von
einem zweiten lockdown insgesamt
ausgehen würde der wäre um ein
vielfaches höher als das was wir jetzt
für diese tests ausgeben deswegen halte
ich das für sehr sinnvoll investiertes
geld
wer seine ferien hinter sich hat kann
sich ab morgen früh auch in bayern
freiwillig und gratis auf corona testen
lassen
auf der rastanlage donautal ost an der
a3 gibt es test kapazitäten für täglich
bis zu 3000 autofahrer
es gibt nicht nur einige wenige corona
hotspots derzeit in deutschland fast
überall steigen die zahlen im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 570 menschen
angesteckt gestern waren es 500
was einen impfstoff gegen das virus
angeht da bahnte
bundesforschungsministerin anja
karliczek vor zu hohen erwartungen
sie rechne frühestens mitte nächsten
jahres mit impfstoffen für die breite
bevölkerung in der türkei werden soziale
medien wie twitter und facebook künftig
stärker kontrolliert das parlament hat
einem entsprechenden gesetz zugestimmt
wie sieht unter anderem vor dass die
ausländischen betreiber in der türkei
ansässige vertreter ernennen müssen
diese können dann haftbar gemacht werden
wenn inhalte im netz gegen geltende
regeln verstoßen
kritiker befürchten zensur und wollen
gegen das gesetz vor gericht sie zurück
nach deutschland was tun wenn die
pandemie so vieles unmöglich macht bei
jugendlichen scheint die eine antwort
darauf recht eindeutig noch mehr zeit im
netz verbringen und zwar am meisten mit
online spielen da steht die tägliche
nutzungsdauer um 75 prozent ergab jetzt
eine studie
und auch das zeigte sich besonders
betroffen sind die deren
nutzungsverhalten ohnehin schon riskant
bis krankhaft war nadia nasa und
stefanie rhein bei ihm rufen eltern an
wenn sie wegen des exzessiven
medienkonsum ihrer kinder nicht mehr
weiter wissen
meist sind es jungs die sich aus der
realen welt ausklinken das macht sich
daran bemerkbar das häufig schulische
leistungen abnehmen dass die schule gar
nicht mehr besucht wird das
sozialkontakte freunde freundeskreise
nicht mehr gepflegt werden als
onlinesüchtig oder gefährdet gelten rund
700.000 kinder und jugendliche vor allem
während der korona epidemie stieg der
medien konsum erheblich so die neue
studie der krankenkasse dak im september
2009 10 spielten jugendliche an
werktagen nach 79 minuten am computer
zur zeit der korona beschränkungen 139
in sozialen netzwerken verbrachten sie
werktags vor corinna zeiten 116 minuten
währenddessen 193 wir werden im nächsten
jahr in einer folgeuntersuchung dann
auch schauen ob daraus ein dauerhafter
anstieg folgt oder ob das zunächst
einmal nur
ein sozusagen corona bedingtes phänomen
gewesen ist
eltern sollten auf warnzeichen achten
doch erkenntnis der studie
in der hälfte der familien zocken die
kinder ohne zeitlimit die politik
reagiert heute mit einem appell an
eltern und erzieher habe keine scheu
davor zeiten zu definieren in denen
handy tabu ist und denkt dran ihr habt
selber vorbildwirkung
jetzt hoffen alle auf den regelbetrieb
in den schulen damit das reale leben
wieder mehr raum einnimmt genauen zum
realen normalen leben gehört für ganz
viele ja auch fußball spielen ja da gibt
es gute nachrichten für millionen
freizeitkicker die durften ja wegen
corona monatelang gar nicht auf dem
platz dann immerhin unter strengen
auflagen trainieren aber ab samstag dann
sind dann sogar freundschaftsspiele
erlaubt als letztes bundesland gab
bayern heute nachmittag grünes licht
nicht nur in hessen ist die fußball-welt
wieder in ordnung wie hier beim
kreisoberligisten fsv winkel dürfen sie
wieder in voller mannschaftsstärke
trainieren und es kommt noch besser wird
ab kommendes wochenende erstmal achte
da war wieder ganz normal fußball elf
gegen elf gespielt werden allein in
bayern gab es laut staatskanzlei bis
heute keine lockerung was die fußballer
noch am morgen empörte es ist wenig
nachvollziehbar warum in württemberg in
baden in hessen in thüringen in sachsen
in tschechien und in österreich also
überall rund um uns herum
freundschaftsspiele zum teil sogar schon
punktspiele mit zuschauern zulässig sind
und wir in bayern noch nicht einmal
testspiele ohne zuschauer austragen
dürfen
vor wenigen stunden aus dem bayerischen
innenministerium dann doch noch die
zustimmung mit der kaum mehr jemand
gerechnet hatte nicht nur die kicker
außerhalb bayerns dürfen sich nun also
auf erste freundschaftsspiele freuen
krone hat auch den us sport hart
getroffen
im baseball wurden jetzt gleich nach
saisonstart viele akteure positiv
getestet der basketball der setzt auf
ein anderes konzept statt durchs land zu
reisen spielen alle teams die restsaison
an einem ort hier im vergnügungspark in
orlando bringen 22 mannschaften der nba
ab morgen das zu ende was mit
corona bedingt ausgesetzt wurde isoliert
abgeschirmt werden alle jeden tag
getestet
wir haben alle so ein fragebogen damit
täglich ausfüllen müssen und da können
die anzeichen schon erkennen und die
machen wirklich einen guten job
der bundesstaat florida zählt in den usa
zu den corona hotspots die spieler
dürfen das riesige gelände nur in
ausnahmefällen verlassen da ist jede
ablenkung willkommen
golfen ist ganz heiß wie leder irgendwie
machen fischen du kannst es brot nehmen
und rausfahren
das konzept der parallelwelt scheint zu
funktionieren bislang sind alle tests
negativ
und jetzt noch zur banksy kannst du
spielt ja nicht mal bei liverpool
nein quatsch ich natürlich berühmter
künstler der hat nur eines seiner
gemälde bei der aktion zerstören lassen
genau so ist es und jetzt wurde wieder
eins versteigert 2,4 millionen euro gab
es für das dreiteilige ölgemälde
mediterraner meeresblick 2007 es
erinnert an die opfer der
flüchtlingskrise den erlös will banking
spenden an ein palästinensisches
krankenhaus in und jetzt passend zu den
millionen noch die lottozahlen
sie lauten 3 15 20 34 35 43 und die
superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
morgen wird es sonnig und warm für die
meisten 25 bis 34 grad die details hat
gleich katja und claus kleber freut sich
auf sie im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn und wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen
wieder dabei sind machen sie sich noch
einen schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute morgen
lagen an den alpen noch die reste der
unwetter von gestern den ganzen tag über
zogen über norddeutschland regenschauer
hinweg und mit dem frischen westwind gab
es eben diese regenschauer und die
dämpfen dann gleich auf die
höchsttemperaturen die lagen deswegen in
norddeutschland heute nur bei maximal 17
bis 22 grad im südwesten wurden dagegen
schon 29 grad erreicht und hier vom
oberrhein flut die hitze ganz
deutschland bis samstag dann werden
schließlich auch an der ostseeküste 25
grad erreicht kaum zu glauben dass es in
dieser nacht einstellige
tiefsttemperaturen gibt in den
mittelgebirgen sinken die werte bis 7
grad
häufig ist es klar und nur die letzten
regenschauer ziehen hier an der ostsee
ab bei westwind
morgen gibt es in norddeutschland noch
ein paar dichtere wolkenfelder sonst
aber strahlt die sonne und es bleibt bei
diesen temperaturen gegensatz in
norddeutschland erwarten uns morgen
höchstwerte zwischen 19 und 22 grad in
der gesamten südwesthälfte geht's aber
auf 27 bis 33 grad rauf und dann kommt
der freitag und damit die hitze mit bis
zu 39 grad ab samstag vertreibt die
schwüle hitze dann gewitter luft vom
besten und am sonntag erreichen die
gewitter den südosten schönen abend noch